I've dealt with lots of people who have
anxiety disorders,
you know,
and one thing about people who have
anxiety disorders is they are not
mysterious to me.
I understand.
It's no problem for me to understand why
people have anxiety disorders or why
they're depressed or why they have
substance use problems.
The mystery to me is always white people
don't have all of those things at once
because everybody has a reason to be
anxious.
In fact,
we have the ultimate reason to be
anxious because we know that we're
vulnerable and we know that we're going
to die and how you can not be anxious
under those circumstances is a great
mystery.
It's a massive mystery and that same
thing applies with regards to depression
and then the same thing applies to some
degree with regards to drug and alcohol
abuse.
As I said last week,
there's plenty of reasons to drown your
consciousness and alcohol.
That's for sure.
We could refer to the aforementioned
anxiety and depression not least and so
and the and the sorts of drugs that
people are prone to take our chemicals
that take the effect of edge off the
tragedy of life.
So,
so back to back to the issue of of of
fear.
Being Abraham is self conscious.
That's what this commentary says,
but the thing is as he moves forward,
despite that,
he's self conscious and he knows the
danger,
but he moves forward despite that and
that's actually the appropriate response
in the face of actual non naive
understanding of what constitutes life.
Like if you're naive and you move
forward,
it's like,
well,
what the hell do you know?
You know there's no courage in naivety
because you don't know what there is to
stop you.
You don't know what dangers you might
apprehend,
but to be aware of what it is that your
problem is.
So to be alert existentially,
let's say,
or to be fully self conscious means that
you're perfectly aware of your
limitations and how you might be hurt
and then to make the decision to move
forward into the unknown and the land of
the stranger.
Anyways,
that's the.
I would say that's one of the secrets to
a good life and I can say that really
without fear of contradiction,
I would I would say because the clinical
literature on this is very,
very,
very clear.
What you do with people who are afraid
and to some degree depressed but
certainly anxious,
is you lay out what what they're anxious
about,
first of all in detail.
What is it that you're afraid of?
What might happen,
and then you decompose it into small
problems,
hypothetically,
manageable problems,
and then you have the person expose
themselves to the thing that they're
afraid of.
And what happens isn't that they get
less afraid.
That isn't what the clinical literature
indicates.
Exactly.
What happens instead is they get braver
and that's not the same thing,
right?
Because if it get less afraid,
it's like,
well,
the world isn't as dangerous as I
thought it was.
You know,
silly me.
If you get braver,
that's not what happens.
What happens is,
yeah,
the World Damn worlds just as dangerous
as I thought,
or maybe it's even more dangerous than I
thought,
but it turns out that there's something
in me that responds to taking that on as
a voluntary challenge and grows and
thrives as a consequence,
and there's no doubt about this.
Even the psychophysiological findings
are quite clear if you,
if you can,
if you impose a stressor on two groups
of people and on one group the stressor
is imposed involuntarily and on the
other group,
the stressor is picked up voluntarily.
The people who pick up the stress or
voluntary voluntarily use a whole
different cycle physiological system to
deal with it.
They use the system that's associated
with approach and challenge and not the
system that's a pro associated with
defensive aggression and withdrawal and
the system that is associated with
challenges,
much more associated with positive
emotion and much less associated with
negative emotion.
It's also much less hard on you because
the defensive posturing system,
the prey animal system,
man,
when that thing kicks in,
it's all systems are go for you.
You know you're the gas is pushed down
to the pedal,
is pushed down to the metal and the
brakes are on.
You're using future resources that you
could be storing for future time right
now in the present to ready yourself for
emergency.
So there's,
there's,
there's nothing simple or trivial at all
about the idea of being called to move
forthrightly forward into this strange
and the unknown and there's a real
adventure that's associated with that,
right?
So that's an exciting thing,
which is part of the reason why people
travel.
And then also to see yourself as the
sort of creature that can do that is
willing to do that on a habitual basis
is also the right kind of tonic for.
I hate this word for yourself.
Esteem,
you know,
because the self esteem has nothing to
do with feeling good about yourself.
As a,
as I already mentioned,
there isn't necessarily reason why a
priority.
You should just feel good about
yourself,
but if you can view yourself acting in a
courageous and forthright manner and
encountering the world and trying to
improve your lot and and and taking
risks,
you know,
in a non naive way,
well then you have something that you
can comfort yourself with at night when
you're wondering what the whole damn
point out of your few tiled and
miserable life and so and that's
necessary because it's often the case
that you wake up at four in the morning
or at least sometimes the case that you
wake up at four in the morning when
things haven't been going that well and
wonder just what the hell the point is
of your futile and miserable life.
You have to have something real to set
against that.
It can't be just rationalizations about
how you know you're a valuable person
among others.
Even though that's true,
that's not good enough.
You need something that's more
realistic.
To set a against that and observing
courage in yourself is definitely one of
the things that that that could help you
sleep soundly at night.
When,
when things are destabilized a little
bit around you.